the memory of microcurrent so many of
you or I guess everybody here knew him
so the my personal goal for today is to
really spread his ideas as far and wide
as possible in you know in his short
career I really had many many beautiful
mathematical ideas with a lot of power
for algorithms and also just to prove
cool mathematical stuff so Michael
worked on three in three main areas I
would say one was randomized numerical
linear algebra this was really his main
focus for a long time and will hear many
talks about this another one which is
intertwined but also slightly more
recent is convex optimization so in
convex optimization he was interested in
the use of convex optimization for
algorithms but also for in convex
optimization for its own sake in
particular in Turpan methods so ung will
tell you a really cool proof that
Michael found this summer about the self
the optimal self concordance of an LP
born this was an open problem for more
than 20 years and you know people like
nemirovsky and Nesterov thought about it
and didn't know to solve it and and
Michael had a wonderful one page proof
is more the third area was online
algorithms so also this was more recent
in a in joint work with with James in
tat Alexander and myself we made
progress on the case server problem but
also this summer when he was with me we
worked on online learning and as far as
I know before coming you know for the
internship he knew nothing for instance
about bandit at the end of the summer it
was I think one of the world expert and
I will just tell you one you know very
cute idea that he had it's really simple
it will take a minute but but it's
really powerful and and people have
missed it in the in the bandit community
so we were working on this program so in
online learning and and and bandit the
entropy is very important okay like in
in many places some of X I log X I so
what you do is that you you play some
you you want to optimize something and
instead of finding really the optimum
you try to regularize with
the entropy now invented there is this
problem of having exploration also
making sure that you explore all the
options sufficiently often so what
people were doing usually what they were
adding a constraint that the excise
should be larger than some gamma okay so
the X is some probability of playing an
action I of seeing what the action I is
gonna do and I think this constraint was
was really annoying and it messed up a
lot of proof in particular for
spasticity reasons so what we did with
with you on Genie that we solve the
spasticity of environment in the medium
and it and the way to do it one really
cute way is instead of just looking at
the entropy you can add to the entropy a
little bit of the log barrier and that
will encourage soft exploration so what
you do is we do minus gamma sum of log
excited so for those of you know
microwave worked out with him this is
really typical Michaels idea like we we
had a really complicated proof and
Michael came with this point of view on
the algorithm which is so simple and and
really clarifies everything so you see
when you add this you remove this
constraint and now you just don't want
the Excite to be too close to zero this
is penalizing you this is forcing you to
have an X I large enough and and someone
we completely miss this idea in medium
and attend and I think this this is
gonna have some consequences in
reinforcement learning and in other
places it's really simple but but very
useful okay that's all I wanted to say
for the introduction we have lots of
fantastic speakers so again the goal is
both to remember Michael but also to
learn about what you did and to to get
some of the gems that he did
mathematically and we will start with
intact this Michael Cohen and Google
Hanna is his Google hangout icon if you
don't know about that
one special thing about micro is he can
do math anywhere including those
internet especially for me when I talk
Murphy and in today I find difficult to
explain stuff without the white spot
before he means very easy
I know he also used every other media to
talk about math so today my main focus
were just to give you about one
paragraph of his google chat message and
then we can try to understand that
together so he is here so I will give
with some PAC one before we think those
sentence one by one so the back when I
see is we all know linear programs this
is important and this is the current
fastest one income of these Pekinese and
22.5 and similarly if you want to solve
a convex program the FATA self-amusing
cube and y2 is those one income roughly
speaking for linear programming if you
use interpoma for ethics code and step
and for convex programming you need to
take and step by using category method
and for proof album you need to both
album be a iterative method each
iteration you little soft some linear
system but actually each linear system
is similar to each other so the main the
second bank pressing years how fast you
can surf those linear system here I give
you a table about for example for linear
program how fast we can stop those
linear system come from unity open
before this form is well study this is
the punch Mac this is just using the
best linear Safa
even in the very first paper about
softening apart they already try to
understand
can we solve this linear system faster
because each time you solving a linear
system very similar to the previous one
and you can see those when income is a
Lima you see the slumber is horrible and
anyway so few years ago Evan and I
caught a kind of tight we saw it locked
tight by certain ease lot I'd ever know
Michael will come to make it really
tight so the problem is lot touches
because of this how we get t square the
way we kept this square is more
precisely here
we have if we can safely in this system
here in time and to Omega Omega is the
matrix multiplicative constant then the
running time more precisely it looks
something like this
two thumps you always need to pay a
better of two to store a dense matrix so
you always have a 2 and the second term
is omega square over 2 Omega plus 1
some crazy lumber but it just happened
Omega is less than 1 per square - and
that's why we recovered the 2 and many
people ask me if the answer is Omega
then what is it title 1 income and turns
out my cuckoo and so you can always do
in the running time like this and then C
of 8 plus T 2 Omega minus 1/2 so what is
peaking how you understand this for
example if you use YouTube for method
with this alpha then your total boiling
time is something like this this part is
kind of difficult to avoid you little
with the matrix squirt beat humps and
this part is how quick you can solve the
linear system and he's so in amortize
the running time is the Omega the best
you can hope yeah so now I will start
trying to go through the message to
understand how he gets a result yet the
top will be really sort so certainly a
start with high usually where he talked
with people usually there's the sentence
before that he saying
I still happen with your people but I
have a simple proof so here he's saying
I am progressing I have a simple proof
for the case ok I should fix the
location say we now have okay now maybe
I fixed a location here to introduce the
poem so the poem is this refusal int
upon each step you need to solve a
linear system of this form
here a is see let me use the same
notation he's using an MP you have an
empty matrix and taboo is the diagonal
matrix so it's ppl no empathy is called
the diagonal matrix is the rating of a
is M PI n certainly this one is in out T
and it's retracing the inter power
output you we waiting and wetter and you
little softest decreasing and what we
know is we have a promise every
iteration those we rating doesn't change
too much more precisely you will have
something like this the multiplicative
change of the we're waiting
in l - l'm changed by something like
less than one and the question is how
fast can we solve this linear system in
amortized time yeah he is crushing yeah
although he said he assumed any is
roughly T but in fact his album can
handle any air and are we go on but I
should have
any question for the setting yeah I will
go on yeah basically just to give you a
rough idea previously people do
something where we complicated many of
the album is randomized where we were
complicated and they didn't get the
title on income as you can see in the
table those one income is super long
mean they'll form a super complicated
but his cell phone is working
and yeah also notice the in the after
you see his paper you wonder why white
is chief URL from you so long before but
you can see from the previous table
people for example even that sort of a
thing about this poem so yeah I still
cannot understand why it is simpler for
me so don't before but anyway we will
see how simplest paper yeah at this
album is autumn or in some sense ok so
now I literally introduce some notation
should go of the album Eustace you want
to maintain each step you want to
maintain this matrix is the different
weighting of the matrix you start it
stands matrix and you want to make sure
you want to make sure the the matrix you
maintain yes whether it goes to the
origin waiting namely for example you
have this
and suppose we already different is
matrix then to softest linear system
mutually to one say P condition gradient
descent using this matrix because you
already started if you have paste you
can softest in d square time so the main
work to to Andrea's this part how can
use maintaining a matrix that is close
to the origin made to the to the matrix
unit itself let's see
and he call he he defied notation X is
okay one thing you want to measure is
this this is the ratio you want the
ratio is one kita fight this is the
disciple update you want to update the
Reaper X and the equivalence here is
same as you want them to be less than
half an autumn yeah we are almost done
it's just one sentence to elfin yeah in
practice is the whole well from here so
I have a lot of time to give the proof
so but but one thing is super converse
is somehow I find proof slightly simpler
than his proof so one go of this talk is
to find a mistake of my loop of because
usually his proof is the uses what so
now I will give the hell
after keeping the album you guys can try
to think about how to prove the elf or
miss covett because he only give one
sentence of proof yeah so the album is
this let me see for each step
give remember those X i if all X is
pitching did I take the absolute value
okay you fo if X is already less than
half then what would you to use you to
laughing then me you keep the everything
to be the same and you don't need to
change the matrix otherwise what do you
do is this you look at all cordially if
X is larger than say 1/4 then you just
change that to be what you really need
otherwise you just keep it now you
little because for this case you update
the reso you need to update the matrix
so this is the alpha if X is less than
1/2 human X I with VI k over wi k plus 1
o minus 1 you want the duration is 1 so
if they goes to one already than you do
love it
the XK is K okay this one okay maybe I
should be more pleased
yeah okay okay I said Y in this way now
then we I K over WI K + 1
yeah so before asking you guys have to
prove this first I want to explain how
you update a week this is a check people
know for really long time even the first
paper the trick is you have a tiger
formula of updating so let you can
always write on the meat duties because
you are only updating a few formula so
the matrix itself is only a by some rank
low rank matrix I call the rankest okay
the lump of coordinate you update so is
Empire Wow okay so tell you you have a
direct formula of updating those the
universe is just some formula
you can think this is look like a
Gaussian amazing the formula is a bit
long but anyways I guess the precise
formula is not very important the
formula is to learn to order
maybe I anyway I am finishing here yet
the key is how fast you can compute this
formula we will remember we already
compute this so also you we we can
compute this exactly by using this
formula so the only term you need to
compute is this now the the Magnificat
term is here this matrix is M PI N and
this is n PI okay the main partner of
implementing this album is multiplying
these two matrix and here you see metric
so you just transfer your outcome here
and then this is our PI R matrix we is
also easy to compare so it turns out you
can just use fast matrix multiplication
you will get the running time look like
this Omega must to say for this talk I
assume Omega is 2.5 k is the bottom that
case then in that case the running time
is n square square okay so now the
question is what is album what is the
total running time of this album yeah I
asked him with that resistor who L phone
there are as why anyone see the reason
why is just one sentence
so yeah here is the sentence the
potential he just gave a potential for
saying that everything is done so let me
explain the potential fencing
yet the potential fencing is this okay
let let me without loss of generality
you can order the X I from largest to
smallest and then he used to potential
summation of X I'm over squirrel hi so
let's see how what happens
I said Laden erased his sentence but
let's see how oh yeah yeah yeah for
example first we see every step how much
you decrease the potential this is every
step you changing the matrix by rank our
matrix and for every change you your
update by at least something like 1 over
4 so every step you would decrease the
potential by by what we scroll ok
because you're summing up 1 over 4 from
square one to square ok so every step
potential be decreased by roughly square
ok and the costs of the album is n
squares go okay and the last thing to
notice is when when the versa we moved
the waiting remember what happens when
when the versa we move the waiting we
have a promise every step the change
multiplicative Li is just less than 1 or
you can bring in this way the the weight
is update by a multiplicative change e
to some apps exponential Epsilon and we
have a promise submission epsilon square
is less than 1 and so now you use you
try to look at how how much the X I
change remember X is something like this
and because the elephant definition the
ratio is always maintained by a constant
and so what specific ating the new one
is something like this you have some e
to epsilon here and because this is look
like a constant so what we speaking this
time is roughly look like X I pass Oh
apps are
so every step that the relative change
is just changed by Epsilon
now you can put Union this the change of
theta is just submitting epsilon I
square I over square i and just coaches
to us based so every step to FICA only
increased by law em screw em every step
of your move you decrease the potential
bicycle rank by using n square school
rank cause that's why the one income
Yamatai sucess square line school lock
em yes sir that is the hope of an and I
still bother why did he in some sense if
you look at this elf of this is the
because every time you will when you
update you will update V to tap you and
your only update owes 4x larger than 1/4
after you update X becomes 0 so X go
from one for to 0 yeah
so that potentially is changed by
submitting 1/4 over what I from I is 1/2
hour okay
yeah I still bother why this is the
simplest profile we was checking for
that llama and until he got a co-ed poof
yeah Kyra this is the simplest proof I
didn't know how yeah I didn't ask you
oh you in fact at that time I don't
fully understand the profile just freak
now you give me proof denser than
probably I can prove it I just
understand yesterday night yeah so I
don't have opportunity to assume but
anyway so so I'm just curious after
looking at this teacher I wonder boy
still next to each other I have with him
here it is the likes to chat would yeah
the let's chitchat and this time he pays
a gift a foot proof of some some some
basic pressing the question we're
studying is the LP progressing and in
one paragraph you saw how to do input
sparsity time and then literally what is
the next teacher so this is energy check
one day later yeah you see there is a
page here and then this one is the
chasing car West at spawn so the problem
is this you have a converse at and the
converse at every step is shrinking and
what you need to do is maintain upon is
inside the converse set and you want to
be much the total movement of after
alpha and say you promise do with your
cover set have the meter 1 and you want
to ask what is the total movement the
previous pass one income is something
like T to the okay T to T and then here
this paragraph is 82 square then yeah
usually I'm pretty polite when it's time
to sleep I will just sleep so I say
ICD blah ho I hope to see ot to be after
wake up and he's out
and you can put volatilities tight yeah
so this is oh thank you I just want to
add that this proof is not only simpler
it like keeps around and the algorithm
that like keeps around way less
information that any of the other
algorithms that were like keeping around
all sorts of partial inversions of
pieces of the matrix and I also think
maybe this one is practical I mean those
beef is when you're so complicated it's
impossible to be practical but this one
may be I think ever has more
okay that's a beam that again
[Applause]